but firstly i want to say
sorry well you have to resign prime
minister it's a failure of leadership
prime minister and i'm sorry for the
things we simply didn't get right and
also sorry for the way that this matter
has been handled i get it and i will fix
it
this report is much worse than i think
many around boris johnson had feared the
first significant thing is the tone of
sue gray's conclusions she says there
needs to be change in number 10 change
in the cabinet office and it needs to
come now secondly sue gray makes clear
that she wants the full findings to come
out maybe as soon as the police
investigation is complete
thirdly she reveals there are 16
different events that she's looking at
that is more than many expected
she also makes clear fourthly that she
was looking at an event in the number 10
flat many expected her not to probe what
went on there but on the day that
dominic cummings left there was
allegedly a party that now appears to be
part of the metropolitan police inquiry
this report by sue gray poses more
questions than it answers i think it's
going to be a very uncomfortable period
for boris johnson